hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are doing apartment boxing part
baking or decorating depending upon
what's in this box
my friend Rosanna she does this really
fun cooking series called nerdy nummies
she also makes really fun lifestyle
videos and you guys know we've done tons
of videos together she also has a baking
line and this is kind of like the second
iteration of the line last year was the
launch and this is some new stuff in
here and I don't even know what's in
here so let's open it up and see this
knife is so incredibly sharp that's a
pink
I'm so excited all of her stuff is so
well thought out and so cute and pretty
and practical let's see what we've got
pink paper these I'm actually quite
excited about so these are like cupcake
tins but she also makes them really
pretty colors too do you guys know what
this is a cupcake pin they call them
swirls but let's be real we all know
what it really is else do we have in
here oh my goodness
speaking of poop swirl candy mold this
is just what everyone needs I should
make some of those from right next party
Oh stamp cookie cutters I've never tried
these before so I'm excited to try that
out what's really cool though is cuz
like they basically will just stamp a
little design onto your cookie
everything looks so good I'm a little
magic tiny little pan to match a cupcake
what a great color palette these are
cute unicorn cupcake decorating kit oh
this is great I think this might be what
I want to make cuz I feel like this is
something that I can handle it probably
won't be messed up the incredible things
that row makes and then I'm over here
like these are little unicorn treat mold
they're probably making other like
chocolate melts all kinds of things in
here
this is something I'm familiar with so
ro and I did a baking challenge we made
princess cakes of each other if you
haven't seen the video be sure to check
it out Wow is that
icing and you freaking delight isn't it
great
Wow all these are so cute these are for
icing and I love the colors purple is
one of my favorite colors this is a
great color I also have a little apron
oh and a hat say no more
I mean I'm gonna look so good how do I
put this on I think I did it wrong he
definitely did it wrong everything
always looks cute on ro you need to play
around a little for the sizing I think I
feel like ratatouille
okay let's make something now
unicorn cupcake decorating kit
everything you need to decorate 12
magical unicorn cupcakes these cute
little pastel sprinkles unicorn ears
look at that little eyes okay let's get
some cupcakes made Wow I was pretty
magical
oh gosh they're so cute these are
adorable this is such a cute pants no
I'm so sorry I'm so sorry little cakes I
was so sorry like I dropped the freaking
pan
Oh some of these got a little squished
I'm just gonna do like a simple little
icing because everything is so organized
now that I don't know where anything is
[Music]
because is a professional cooking show
extremely professional
we've got rose little bags James my son
is forgot to put the freaking tip in bad
I'll just cut it and clearly already
screwed this up how can I forget to do
the most important part I think these
are still gonna look beautiful
they forgot to put a dip in this so
let's just hope that this works okay I
probably should have started from the
outside and then worked my way around
each one has a little bit of personality
just like people some people have better
ones let's hear for you if these are
edible
hmm they are can you hear the crunching
oh yeah yeah I'm sorry oh wow put your
ear over there
okay let's spit into little unicorn
horns these are actually candles these
are so easy to make that I can even
handle it so that is saying something
okay now I got to put a little bit of
sprinkles on them just a little bit just
for like a little yep
you should have cut a smaller hole well
I guess since we're here I'm just gonna
use the whole packet
here they are
our little unicorn cupcakes I actually
had a lot of fun making these and this
is incredibly easy I mean pretty much
everything that you need to make them is
in the kit even get the little cupcake
liners there's a little eyes on it I'll
put a link in the description if you
guys want to check out this step from
Rose baking line now I'm gonna like put
this in the freezer because I never
gonna forget what a good job I did let
me know if there's anything else you'd
like to see me bake here on my channel
or even if it's non baking related what
kind of videos would you guys like to
see leave those in the comments below
and I will see you guys in my next video
but I'll only see you if you hit the
bell because that's basically the only
way that you'll be notified also be sure
to subscribe and hopefully I will see
you soon okay that's that's it
the funny bone is not funny here vacuum
right up
[Music]